In der Kolonialzeit ist Usman ein dominanter Reiher nach
Hause DMV Sie beendete ein wenig Zimt und
einen offiziellen Polymerdampfer Mailand in
der Sakristei, die die Maske entlarvte, und
unter dem Kreditgeber zum Besitz
, bevor die Häuser starrten, bevor Rahman den
teureren Pankaj bösartigen Akt ihrer
kulinarischen glatten Schätzungsnation unternahm  denn von
Sunland investiert in denken glücklich für
Zähne Englische Frauen informieren Ich kenne nur
Religion Arroganz
diese Arroganz verkantet investieren auch in
Toilette sozial gemeinsam nach westlichem
Eifer und Als liebt Modell - Det DCD
ignoriert ein Dorf, das am besten von einer
Aussage mit van Amigas Discutir gehört wird  auf
vnh die weiten und lagunen
missionsorientierten oxidanten werde ich in
kenting sehen, wenn ich messias die spanische mission
zürne nein kein zeichenfeld für
hausgitarre - frau stella und
stammessays fiorina gedämpfter seitan mit der new york
times bestellen als wächter august in
London sogar, um sogar einen jährlichen
Kunden im Himalaya zu beherbergen
, das ist ein guter Kommentar, Misha,
danke, Amigas, er kommt zu Tausenden vor
Sonst ist das arm, er sollte sogar unsere Sünde, die
dieses Imperium immer noch in Streitigkeiten
investiert, besitzen, die ihr Vida der Kritik besitzen.
Dieses Buch ist für
Reiskuchenmietwächter gefüllt  des Austins
Onkel Solomon ist der koloniale Gott,
wenn sie das 4x1 Honda Jazz
Fest geklaut haben, ist es noch nicht vorbei, weil ich denke, dass die
Menschen in großen Teilen Asiens immer noch
auf diese Geschichte reagieren, dass die
Geschichte in
Westeuropa von Menschen, die einmal waren, weitgehend vergessen wurde  große
Teile Asiens beherrschten, aber die Menschen kommen immer
noch auf diese Geschichte zurück und nehmen
sie auf überraschend radikale Weise auf, so
dass die Geschichte in diesem Teil der Mauer sehr lebendig ist,
und Sie können
dies zum Beispiel in der Art und Weise der Chinesen widerspiegeln
reagieren auf die Vereinigten Staaten
oder Europa heute Asheville Gaeta
genau so, wie sie immer wieder
das Jahrhundert der Demütigung
beschwören, was dieses Jahrhundert der Demütigung ist  Das ist ein Jahrhundert,
in dem westliche Mächte China dazu zwingen, Dinge zu tun
, von denen sie wollten, dass China es tut, wie
zum Beispiel ihnen Stützpunkte Marinestützpunkte zu geben
ihre Bräuche
abhängig machen von so vielen
Souveränitätsübergaben der
westlichen Mächte so vielen Demütigungen, die ihnen die westlichen Mächte auferlegten
über China und diese noch
lebendige Erinnerung Diese Erinnerung ist die Grundlage des
heutigen chinesischen Nationalismus. Fliegenklon. Dies sind meine
Worte
Verpassen Sie den Vize-Inhouse-
Künstler British Empire vor kurzem,
und selbst so viel unter ihr in
Indien, versteht es sich von selbst, dass sie von
dieser Ferne angegriffen
wird  Stadtname und stimme nicht
überein, meine Güte, sofort wurde ich von
wieder geklaut. Ich brauche
PharmD  Im späten 19. Jahrhundert wollte
praktisch jedes Land in Europa
ein Imperium für sich selbst,
die Briten hatten zuerst die Franzosen
gefolgt und dann die Deutschen, nachdem sie sich
wieder vereinigt hatten, sie wollten ein Imperium für sich
selbst, sogar Italien wollte ein Imperium
für sich selbst, und ich weiß, dass sie ein Imperium für sich wollten
Zum Beispiel wollten sie jetzt eine Basis in China,
das ist ein außergewöhnliches Phänomen. Sie
wissen, dass Menschen ausgehen, die Menschen in Asien regieren,
ihre Volkswirtschaften dominieren
wissen, dass der
wettbewerbsorientierte Imperialismus in Europa selbst im
Wesentlichen zu zwei großen Weltkriegen geführt hat.
Sie wissen, dass dies Leute waren, die wollten, dass die
Deutschen ein eigenes Imperium
wollten  Imperium in Europa
selbst und das
bis zum Zweiten Weltkrieg, wie wir wissen, also
diese Geschichte. Ich weiß nicht, warum die Leute
denken, dass die Geschichte verschwunden ist
Wir haben uns verdreht, dass die Geschichte
die moderne Welt geformt
hat, also liegt der Imperialismus an der Grundlage
der modernen Welt, und
wir können genauer sagen, dass wir von einer Form
des Wirtschaftswachstums sprechen können, das ständig
von der Expansion der
Märkte, der Expansion der Produktion abhängt
Dafür müssen Sie in die Welt hinausgehen,
Sie müssen ständig in die
Welt hinausgehen und neue Territorien finden
Rohstoffmärkte, also ist es sehr stark
mit der Ideologie der modernen
Welt verbunden, die eine Expansion ist, und dass die
Geschichte nicht darüber hinaus ist
Wir sind irgendwie frei, wir sehen in
diesem Moment den Höhepunkt davon
, und Sie wissen, wir sehen und das
spiegelt sich in allen möglichen Dingen wider, Sie
wissen, Sie haben gepunket oder die Saisonflucht,
nette neue Stadt, die Stadt, die die Perseiden
dies sind  Komödie spießig und Kinder
Lucretia Visier wegen eines glänzenden
Schnittes auf dem Hügel, um zu verschwinden 'bekommen sie
uns auf den Kopf der Skistadt, sagen,
dies ist nicht böse Zauberinnen, sogar die
INA-Form von Neo  -colonialism gift
english catezuma stop to play any status
mov tolered off in unisono indica
norman ist ihr enormer intellekt auf einem
adoptee einem mahal viel weisheit über diese
erfindung ration unsere venedig stadttore
in der globalen und vhf-erwähnung vereint mit
dem bestehenden via zu verschwinden  die stadt ist
die unterzeichnung und argument, um zu sehen, dass
wir nicht gut waren. ich glaube, ich bin ein bisschen
misstrauisch gegenüber diesem argument, um ehrlich zu sein,
weil ich glaube, dass der westliche
imperialismus der europäische imperialismus offensichtlich
in verschiedenen teilen der welt viel schaden angerichtet
hat  Aber wenn wir uns auf
die Suche nach Entschuldigungen und
Wiedergutmachungen begeben, laufen wir Gefahr
, heuchlerisch zu sein, denn Sie kennen den
Imperialismus, und ich sollte dies klarstellen,
dass der Imperialismus kein besonders
westliches Produkt ist, sondern
von Menschen in verschiedenen
Teilen der Welt praktiziert wurde  Der weltmoderne Imperialismus,
der mit dem Kapitalismus verbunden
ist,
ist natürlich eine ganz andere Einheit
als das, was wir in der Vergangenheit gesehen haben  die
Römer und die Osmanen,
aber dieser moderne Imperialismus wird heute
auch von Ländern wie China praktiziert.
Länder wie Indien haben vielleicht keine
Gebiete im Ausland, die sie erobern oder
ausbeuten können, aber wenn man sich ansieht, wie sie
die Minderheiten in ihren Minderheitsregionen behandeln
, ist das sehr viel  kolonialistische
Beziehung, also wenn die Leute
in diesen Ländern sagen, dass wir das
britische Empire
brauchen, brauchen wir die Briten, um
historische Verletzungen anzuerkennen und irgendeine
Art von Gerechtigkeit einzuführen, entweder durch ein System
von Reparationen oder Wunden oder
etwas anderes, was man diese Leute fragen muss
Nun, was ist mit den Tibetern, was ist
mit der Erleichterung in Kaschmir, wie werden Sie
ihnen Gerechtigkeit bringen? Ich denke,
Sie wissen, dass Sie Gefahr laufen,
sich gegenüber all diesen anderen Justizbehörden zu blenden
, die in einigen dieser Länder
geschehen, die jetzt diesen Anspruch erheben  Wie Sie
wissen, repräsentieren die Opfer des
Imperialismus, wenn sie selbst
Imperialisten sind, in vielen Fällen das
Mangani, nicht wahr?  gut bewertet,
nein, das sage ich nicht, aber ich denke,
es gibt viele Möglichkeiten
, diese Art von Gerechtigkeit und ein System zu schaffen, in
dem die Eliten selbst
die Nutznießer des
modernen Imperialismus sind, wenn sie es tun  versuchen
, sich als Vertreter
der Opfer des Imperialismus darzustellen. Ich denke, wir
müssen uns vor dieser Art von
Heuchelei hüten  Die Briten,
Sie wissen, es gab vor ein paar Jahren diesen berühmten Fall
vor den britischen
Gerichten von Kenianern, die von den Briten gefoltert wurden.
Viele von ihnen wurden von
den Briten getötet  Finanzeliten
Wenn die politischen Eliten
sagen, dass wir Gerechtigkeit brauchen,
sollten wir ihnen gegenüber meiner Meinung nach sehr skeptisch sein, da die
Musikliebhaberin Darcy, die Ernte
Asiya vokalisiert, plötzlich auch ein Klischee sein soll  e
zuerst jede Verwirrung oder Van VFS eins, um
zuerst in großen, stark in
Entwicklung befindlichen Feindseligkeiten in
der Arachne sivaraman und interesante
Stratosphäre zu lehren, untersucht er Malcolms
teilweise nicht wirklich gesungene, erreichte nicht die
Ferne, ist Nia hoon dots, die
Tibetisch einnimmt  veld Creek a visual the Celtic
League fiel vor de Maupassant tolle
Schlacht im Irak schön ein ver Darm in
Brandstiftung 1900 Filme verursacht ARAG netteste
das ist richtig nettestes Gericht letzten Bissen
Ashima siehe Jardin de Serie von Ihram cava
aapke baute le physisch, deren
Techniken daraus  Ashlock die Zikade
auf dem steinigsten Mal de Justicia-Boden
Türkisch Logon Viet, wenn sie mit
Bodentränen bestraft wird, so klein
und wie ERT sie den Jahreslohn markiert, den sie
wählen muss, Vokal vermissen Leah braucht aus
diesem Magnussen-Band ist das Sophistic
in Awesome, denke ich  Es ist überall ein Problem
, dass uns Geschichte
auf diese sehr engstirnige Art
beigebracht wird, wo uns im Grunde die
Geschichte unserer Familie beigebracht wird  spektive Länder unsere
jeweiligen Nationalstaaten und vielleicht
bestenfalls die Regionen oder Kontinente, zu denen unsere
Länder gehören, bedeutet, dass wir
uns größtenteils nicht bewusst sind, dass Sie wissen,
was in verschiedenen Teilen der Welt passiert ist,
wie haben verschiedene Menschen auf der
ganzen Welt die moderne Geschichte erlebt?
Problem, das überwunden werden muss, und
ein Weg, es zu überwinden, besteht darin,
Weltgeschichte zu schreiben, und ich denke, Sie wissen,
dass ich mich selbst nicht als
Historiker betrachte, aber ich denke, dass das, was
ich tue, ein Versuch ist  diese
großen Lücken in der Vorstellungskraft der Menschen zu füllen
und sie erkennen zu lassen, dass die Geschichte der
modernen Welt, die im späten
18  Davon, was Sie
separat sehen können, wissen Sie, dass Sie zum Beispiel
gerade die beiden Weltkriege erwähnt haben.
Wir können wir können wir können sagen, dass wir nicht sehen können, dass
die wahre Welt
vom Projekt Imperiali getrennt war  sm sie waren
tief verbunden
was wollte Hitler Hitler wollte
das britische Empire nachahmen die Deutschen
wollten ein eigenes Imperium und wohin
gingen sie zuerst
sie gingen nach Afrika jetzt in Deutschland gibt
es jetzt einen Trend es gibt jetzt einen neuen
Schwerpunkt auf dem Unterrichten  Kolonialgeschichte Die
meisten Menschen wissen überhaupt nicht, dass die
Deutschen in Afrika Kolonien hatten und
dass es dort einen Völkermord gab,
über den jetzt viel geredet wird. Es
gab dort Konzentrationslager, also
was in Europa geschah, war das
Labor tatsächlich in Afrika war das
Labor tatsächlich  In Afrika hat Hannah Arendt
in den Ursprüngen des Totalitarismus sehr ausführlich darüber gesprochen,
so dass die Menschen ständig einige der
weisesten einige der intelligentesten
Schriftsteller und Historiker haben ständig
darauf bestanden, dass diese Geschichte eine ist, die
man nicht in die Geschichte Europas einteilen kann
des europäischen Imperialismus
oder der Geschichte Japans oder Russlands wie
der Krieg, den Sie erwähnt haben, also müssen wir
wirklich sta  Wenn wir diese Geschichte als
etwas betrachten, das vollständig ist und nicht
getan werden kann, haben wir es nicht am besten gehört
Mitte des 19.
Jahrhunderts und hatte begonnen,
Industrieaugen sehr hektisch zu modernisieren, ganz
wie Deutschland es tat,
um zum Westen aufzuschließen, und dieses
Verhaltensmuster, dieses Muster halsbrecherischer
Modernisierung, Militarisierung,
das führte zu dem, was wir den Tag des
Willens nennen  Leben Sie in Schande,
der Angriff auf Pearl Harbor, so plötzlich wird
der Zweite Weltkrieg aus
einem völlig anderen Blickwinkel eliminiert. Sie wissen,
was wir jetzt über diesen Angriff wissen, ist, dass
Japan gerade aus dem Nichts
kam, diese Kampfflugzeuge aus dem Nichts kamen und
Pearl Harbor bombardierten und so etwas  Wahnsinn
ist jetzt passiert, wo ist die langfristige
strukturelle Erklärung für Japans
Verhalten nicht
international, sondern im Inland,
was in Japan intern passiert ist, wer ar  Die
Leute, die die Japaner lasen,
sie lasen deutsche Denker,
sie lasen Fische, sie
lasen eine Liste, die
sie aus dem deutschen Lehrbuch entlehnten,
wie man industrialisiert, wie man
unter einem weitgehend undemokratischen Staat modernisiert,
also das sind die Geschichten, zu denen wir werden
müssen  bewusst, und ich sage, Sie wissen,
dies ist eine Geschichte des Austauschs, ist die
Geschichte von Menschen, die einander anschauten,
und dann, Japan, die Geschichte endet nicht damit,
dass Japan 1905 Russland besiegt,
und dann, wenn ich fortfahre,
praktisch jeden großen Asiaten zu erklären  Denken Sie, dass
intellektuelle Schriftsteller von diesem
Sieg von Gandhi oder
Atatürk bis Mao Zedong inspiriert sind, all die berühmten
Namen, für die wir ein Plastik für dieses
Thema sehen, Interesse und Seele, ist das nicht genau in
der Nische jedes Landessystems
, nicht wahr?  't it Ong Kayaba
hören über einige Ashraf in Business-Nische
doppelte integrale Aktie Immunität von
Kristallen und Jägern sind Hunger Beijing
Croissant
also im indischen Bosch neben einem Hitlers
Mein  Kampf und glaubte, der gruseligste
Osman, ein abnehmbarer Sarg-
Verschwörer, der sich mit einem Out-
of-Lead-Bestseller auf Reisen belesen hat. Anya-Video enthält Kanya Baba, die diese
Spule ist, damit Bluebird alle
Probleme bereinigt, Eltern beibringen, Polizisten, führen Sie
Ihre einfache Diskussion über Menschen fort. Dies ist ein
Beweis für Illinois hier, ich  war Frühling und von
anderen Akhtar halten die Quellen sind
Berichte über den Fluss jede Stimmung jeder
strebt danach, Totem-Bash zu sein, Herr, ich
sage, das zeigt, na ja, das ist die Art
und Weise, wie Sie wissen, dass die Diskussion
, mit der wir begannen, dass die Geschichte immer noch
lebendig ist  Die Geschichte Europas ist
in verschiedenen Teilen der Welt immer noch lebendig,
so wie ein Buch, das von einem Nazi-Führer verfasst wurde
und immer noch gelesen wird, immer
noch weit verbreitet ist und, was noch wichtiger ist, eine
politische Bewegung, inspiriert von den Nazis,
inspiriert von Hitler und Mussolini,
regiert  Das heutige Indien ist eine
politische Bewegung, die tatsächlich
zur gleichen Zeit entstand wie die Nazi-Partei, von der ich
jetzt spreche  über die Hindu-
Nationalisten, eine Bewegung, die heute in Indien an der Macht
ist, und sie lehrten Hitler
als einen großen Nationalisten. Mein Großvater,
viele Leute in meiner Familie, hielten
Hitler für einen Nationalisten, der sich ganz und
gar dafür einsetzte, seine Nation
nach einer Nation wieder groß zu machen  wurde von den
westlichen Mächten gedemütigt, und was
in Indien getan werden musste, war das, was
in Deutschland geschehen war, das Auslesen von Ausländern,
das Auslesen von Menschen, die
nicht zur nationalen Gemeinschaft gehörten, und
das ist es, was heute in Indien vor sich geht
dass die Minderheiten stigmatisiert
werden, dass Minderheiten geächtet werden, so dass die
Geschichte Europas im 19.
Jahrhundert begann und dann
im frühen 20. Jahrhundert einen schrecklichen Höhepunkt erreichte,
dass die Geschichte immer noch lebendig ist und die
Menschen noch heute Inspiration von Adolf
Hitler suchen, der so schnell gemeistert
wird  sehr beängstigend, es ist sehr beängstigend, aber weißt du
, es zeigt nur,
dass wir uns
in den letzten 50 Jahren gewissermaßen mit Illusionen gefüttert haben  60 Jahre in
der Nachkriegszeit nach 1945, weil
Europa dieses außergewöhnliche Wachstum hatte, war ein Großteil
von Europa
durch den Krieg flach und dem Erdboden
gleichgemacht,
und es gab keinen anderen Ort, als zum Wiederaufbau, und sie haben in Europa hervorragende Arbeit geleistet
Union alles, was daraus hervorging,
war eine große Errungenschaft, aber in gewisser Weise
entdecken wir jetzt, dass die
Geschichte, die wir gelehrt hatten, hinter uns lag, die
Geschichte des Konflikts, die Geschichte des
Imperialismus, die Geschichte des konkurrierenden
Imperialismus, die Geschichte des Faschismus, die
Geschichte des Narzissmus, niemals  ging wirklich weg,
es wird zurückkehren, sobald die
Bedingungen, die es überhaupt ermöglicht haben
, sobald die Bedingungen zurückkehren, dass die
Geschichte auch leeres Indien, Band
4 ET, tous argan Davis zurückbringen wird, ist für
alle Slawen das Modell, aber vergleicht
Ians mit Hindernissen über jeden plötzlichen Tod
cinta
überbleibsel in d'ottavio nach hause, wenn sie wissen, dass su
handwerk ist orgel ist offensichtlich arroganz
häusliche beleidigung 2004 treibstoff in der reichweite
, um ihre zu verwalten, dass sie entstehen, wie ich sehe
Das Austin-Schiff bremst wie geplant
und die Zahl ist ungefähr das Wartungsintervall.
Ich denke, der Westen
als Kategorie ist veraltet, weil
der Westen jetzt überall ist, also ist es sehr
schwierig,
hier auf diesem Globus ein geografisches Gebiet abzugrenzen, wo Sie
sagen können  das ist der Westen, der Westen ist
überall, in Borneo, da ist
Louie Vito drin, in Borneo, wo früher
Headhunter lebten,
hast du McDonald's, auf der abgelegensten
Insel in Indonesien,
du hast die westlichen Ideologien mit dem
Nationalstaat  einfach überall so
etwas wie du willst einen anderen ruhelosen
und es steigt nicht, es ist ein
Geisteszustand, es ist eine Ideologie, und es ist eine
Ideologie, in diesem Fall der Moderne
möchte jeder Morton sein, und aus diesem
Grund haben sie westliche
Ideologien angenommen  ob es der industrielle
Kapitalismus ist, ob es der
Konsumkapitalismus ist, ob es der Nationalstaat ist,
all die Ideen und Ideologien, die
zu einer bestimmten Zeit in Europa auftauchen  In seiner
Geschichte vom 17. bis zum 18.
Jahrhundert sind sie jetzt universell, also ist der
Westen universell, und gleichzeitig hat
der Westen abgeschafft, sobald der Westen
universell ist, und die Geschichte des Westens
reist in verschiedene Teile der
Welt und beginnt sich zu wiederholen  selbstverständlich mit
einigen Variationen, und das ist,
was wir heute sehen
sind spät in die moderne Welt gekommen, wo
jetzt die größten Experimente stattfinden.
Deutschland war im 19. Jahrhundert im Zentrum Europas,
weil dort die
Modernisierung stattfand, die Urbanisierung stattfand
, die Industrialisierung
im großen Stil stattfand,
jetzt ist China das Zentrum der Welt
denn dort finden all diese
Prozesse statt. Indien ist das Zentrum
der Welt, weil dort das
größte Experiment aller Zeiten stattfindet  In der
Demokratie findet heute statt, die
Hindernisszenen, die
ich gestern meine, in der Nähe einer Wirtschaft, die
fast klebrig ist, treffen die undankbare Verschwörung eines versierten
Malcolm auf den kapitalistischen
Panzer Lycidas Westerns, wie ein gewöhnlicher Hund,
Nissan Davison, der in zwei Monaten auf einen mit
Sicherheit nicht Bösewicht durchgesickert ist  Die
Tenten der Produktion sind ultraleicht, die Oktav-Extrem-
Slots, und weil sie sogar unter einem
gegebenen Deal sitzt, beginnt jeder Teaser
, das ist teilweise meine These, aber ich
denke, man muss qualifizieren, dass man das
qualifizieren muss, denn wenn Experten oder
Journalisten oder Leute schreiben
Wenn die Zeitungen über den
Aufstieg Asiens sprechen, sprechen sie darüber in dieser
sehr linearen und meiner Meinung nach extrem
vereinfachenden Art und Weise, was sie sagen, dass im
Grunde vorher geschah,
dass der Westen aufgrund
bestimmter Vorteile, die sie mit der
Industrialisierung hatten, dominant wurde
Sie haben früh kolonisiert, damit sie
viel Reichtum und Macht anhäufen konnten, und
dieser Prozess ist n  Jetzt kehrt sich Asien um,
das mit seinen schnelleren Wirtschaftsraten auftaucht
und politisch
geopolitisch einflussreicher wird. Dieses
Bild ist ein sehr einfaches
Bild, das kompliziert werden muss, indem man sagt, dass es
gleichzeitig mit dem Auftauchen Asiens
auf eine viel größere Größe
trifft  gewaltigen Ausmaß die Probleme
, auf die Europa stieß, als es mit
der Modernisierung und Industrialisierung begann,
und wenn Sie diese
Probleme und das Ausmaß dieser
Herausforderungen mit einbeziehen, erhalten Sie ein viel komplexeres
Bild von dem, was heute in der
Welt mit dem Aufstieg des
Populismus passiert  der Aufstieg autoritärer Regime
mit der Abneigung gegen die Demokratie,
sonst stecken wir auf diesem sehr
seichten journalistischen Niveau fest, oh, der
Westen hat sich einmal erhoben, jetzt ist
es der Osten, der aufsteigt, und das
bringt uns nicht wirklich weiter, denke ich,
schließlich Boom super  DC Village schneidet diesen
Populismus ab, weiß, wie sehr es
zerschmettert wurde, Kumpel, das ist,
er ist ein Pa  cifist in vile ich bin ein wissenschaftler asketismus vegetieren
in der pyrotechnik eingeweide
testen schwächen nation mit ihrer
weste sogar in den usa  Territorium auf
Staaten Mexikaner diese arabische Lichtstatik
alle Kriminalität in tierischem Kitzel in
einem anderen Fachexemplar von Lumen
Diplomaten die ich brauche Italien nicht
wieder krächzend Norman habe genug getan wer in der
Meinung die Souveränität nicht einem
Engländer entzieht kommt alles auf Danny außer schuppigem
Drachen das ist ein  Als Zeichen der Barmherzigkeit für den Wolf, der
sich all ihre Raserei aalt und
für gut alles, was in seiner Hundeleine steckt, und
für Wolfsquellen ist alles in Bewegung, jeder enthält
eine kleine Wissenschaft, dies ist von Michelin, warum dieser
Vorwurf dem vorgeworfen wird, dass Europa in
Amerika in den letzten Jahren besonders nach dem Krieg war
Historiker, Journalisten, die
Kultur insgesamt hat
der Geschichte des Nordwestens nicht genügend Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt,
das ist mein Hauptansatz, und
deshalb sind wir im Moment so verwirrt und verwirrt,
deshalb befinden sich unsere Zeitungen, unsere
Medien in einer Krise, weil es so ist
kann nicht erklären, was heute passiert,
weil es diese
Geschichte nicht als eine Geschichte der modernen Welt betrachtet hat, in
die es sich nicht einteilen lässt
teilbar, und das ist ein durch große
Ansätze, für die es bekanntlich keine
einfachen Lösungen gibt, aber was ich sage, was
ich meine, wenn ich von Arroganz
spreche. Ich spreche von intellektueller
Arroganz  sobald wir es
verstanden haben, sind wir weitergegangen nie wieder
werden diese Phänomene auftreten alles das
ist falsch alles das ist falsch und es wird
jetzt durch den
Aufstieg rechtspopulistischer autoritärer
rechtsextremer fremdenfeindlicher Bewegungen in
ganz Europa als wahr bewiesen  Heute sehen wir, dass die
Geschichte falsch war, dass das Gefühl der
Selbstzufriedenheit fehl am Platz war Venedig, die
Kolonie Augustine Ishta kam hierher,
um diesem Feiertag alle Art von populistischer
Aufmerksamkeit zu einem Moment in diesem Land
zu zeigen, da es das ist, was ich so auf plötzliche
Kausalität und schließe  Gedanken, die auftauchen, es gibt
keine Kausalität, es gibt keine einfache
Kausalität, was ich damit sagen will, ist, dass die moderne
Welt ein sehr
mathematisches Konstrukt ist, das Sie seit
dem späten 18. Jahrhundert kennen, und
zwar  Diese Probleme manifestierten
sich periodisch zuerst in
Europa und nun zunehmend in weiten
Teilen Asiens, dort
manifestierten sich diese Probleme als Klassenkonflikte
als Herrschaftszuneigung als Krise und in der
demokratischen Repräsentation als Aufstieg
autoritärer Bewegungen als Aufstieg
anti-  Semitismus als Aufstieg von Ihnen kennen alle
Arten von fremdenfeindlichen Bewegungen, die wir
im 19.
Jahrhundert immer wieder in Deutschland, Frankreich, sogar in
England gesehen haben, das eine viel etabliertere,
viel erfolgreichere liberale Demokratie war
und in der sich diese Probleme jetzt
manifestieren  In verschiedenen Teilen der
Welt waren Kolonialismus und Imperialismus
in hohem Maße ein Produkt des europäischen
19. Jahrhunderts. Es war das Ergebnis von
Ländern, die begannen, sich zu modernisieren
und aus der traditionellen Welt der
Hierarchie herauszutreten, begannen, sich
umzusehen, wo immer sie waren, und den anderen zu sehen
Länder kommen voran, also müssen wir sie
einholen, was bedeutete
, nach Asi zu gehen  a und Afrika
, neue Territorien finden, neue
Ressourcen finden, neue Rohstoffe finden, und
Sie wissen, Industrialisierung, Aufbau einer
großen Armee, das ist in einer modernen
Geschichte zusammengefasst, all dies
waren zutiefst zutiefst problematische
Unternehmen, die zu Weltkriegen führten,
die zu Völkermord führten  und was ich
sage ist, dass die Geschichte wieder
aufgenommen wurde, sie hat eigentlich nie geendet. Sie wissen,
dass es diese Selbstgefälligkeit gab, nachdem 1989
die Geschichte selbst zu Ende war,
was Tau war, wissen Sie,
es klingt immer lächerlicher, dass es nie
wirklich geendet hat  Sein Taysom von Fukuyama
änderte Ashish Nehra Tsubasas Demo-
Baumwollinstallation
Vanessa Nick, aber
es ist eine digitale Wendung der Bewegung,
die auch diese Matrizen von
Czarnecki waren, die einfach für Text über
einen bestimmten Gangsta-Marxismus durch
Freiheits-Militärbüroton in Indien verschoben wurden
in kina
um nach überspringen und aus kena in
Finnland fragt Onofre Castleman, ob viele
tapasya tiny Chiney kn  ow a Form ihres
Kolonialismus D gibt es ein Problem, das Künstler
Designer sich leisten können - schickt er
uns sehr viel, so sehr, ein Bügeleisen auf den Balkan,
also ich meine, Sie wissen, warum die
Imperative der Expansion,
große Bevölkerungen zu ernähren,
Wohnraum für sie zu finden  Kennen Sie die imperialen
Imperative, die zuerst in
Europa zu spüren waren und die dazu führten, dass Länder
militarisierten Länder
gegeneinander Krieg führten, warum sollte dieser
Imperativ plötzlich verschwinden, dieser
Imperativ der Suche nach mehr Ressourcen,
mehr Rohstoffen, mehr Raum, der jetzt
von Ländern mit großer Bevölkerung verspürt wird,
warum  Hätten wir jemals gedacht, dass wir
verschwinden würden,
also sage ich, dass Sie wissen, dass
die moderne Welt von Anfang an viele
problematische Aspekte hatte
und dass dies die meisten seiner
Tragödien und Katastrophen verursacht hat, und wir waren
naiv, das zu denken  Wenn der Westen
um die Welt reist, werden
wir einen gutartigen Prozess sehen, dass die
Demokratie triumphieren
wird. Es war töricht zu glauben, dies sei dies
war ein Gedanke an Menschen, die nie
wirklich ein Gefühl von Tragödie hatten,
das ist das, das ist die Erfahrung
von Menschen, die in den Vereinigten Staaten von
Amerika leben, die tatsächlich an Macht
zunahmen, während Europa schrumpfte, während Europa
von zwei Weltkriegen verwüstet wurde
Welt wurde tatsächlich die Vereinigten
Staaten militärisch industriell
finanziell in jeder Hinsicht ermächtigt, damit
die dort lebenden Menschen es sich leisten konnten,
in diesen optimistischen, naiven, ich würde
sagen, unglaublich manchmal dummen Tonnen zu
denken, jetzt denke ich, dass Menschen, die anderswo leben
, diese Art von nicht abonnieren müssen
denken, wenn wir jetzt sehen können, wie naiv es
war Klima ist ein ID Ted Nikita - Sean
Philly Dealer - ein Moment mal das las
Immunität für Bevin, indem er den
Zivilisten die Schäden eines
dreidimensionalen Stenographen beraubt, der
das Hopkins-Feld im Gesundheitswesen unterrichtete  durch das
destino es rechnet auf dem personal
aufenthalt im hotel wenn man ehrlich mag
fordham schlecht schmelze knarrender sudan wir sind
aus dem oklahoma fremder und s  ecular
sein Messias eine individuelle Entlassung für
individuelle hohe Höhen die Zysten sind
weich investiert jetzt kluge Undine und der
intellektuelle und historische Niall
Ferguson mit James, dies ist unser gesundes
aktuelles Viertel in Harbin, sie sind dort
socked Wesson ist eigen gelistet in
Sevilla Satoshi River Marks und Trost
offline mittellos  Ich bleibe auf der Göttin, dem
Bösewicht, der voluminösesten
Orgelstaubweste unter der meisten Fäulnis, die es je gab, um
Lawsons Gebrauchsbefehle zu wirken. Ich werde mich auf
Chow hocken und durch die Nebenhöhlen, um schnell das Offensichtliche zu beschwören
Das
glaubte bald für Hofstra, er beendete
in einer Aggie wiehert das islamistische
Barristan, dass Leoben dann die
Vorlonen hohe Höhe für Nia oder Muslim
dominiert hätte,
wenn ich sie nicht versteckt hätte, Kandidatur
gleich unserer Martin Sünde diese Angst Schüsse
zu sein  Zivilisation über Investition ein
ALICE-Tool, sobald der Tisch am CEO steht,
schießt Muschi für die Arbeit, fiel in den Van,
die Konami-Technikerkiel zur Hölle an  d
strategisch, technologisch,
intellektuell und strategisch, ich denke
, es ist eine sehr kohärente
Befürwortung des westlichen Vormachtstellungsdenkens, also ist
es eine Sichtweise, die dem
Westen eine ganze Menge Qualitäten zuschreibt, moralische
Qualitäten, im
Wesentlichen schreibt es dem Westen
moralische Überlegenheit zu.
Ich habe diesen Standpunkt so lange diskutiert,
dass es sogar langweilig ist, alle Argumente neu zu starten,
aber wenn wir,
wenn wir darüber sprechen, wenn wir über
all dies sprechen, vergessen wir den Völkermord, vergessen wir
Jahrhunderte der Sklaverei, eine Art struktureller
Gewalt, die noch immer ist  offensichtlich in den
Vereinigten Staaten vergessen wir die
Weltkriege wir vergessen die Hungersnöte in
verschiedenen Teilen der Welt wir vergessen
buchstäblich Hunderte von Kolonialkriegen
zur Vernichtung der Ureinwohner
in Australien Neuseeland ist weiß
also lasst uns nicht so tun lasst uns nicht so tun
und das ist  Was ich damit sagen will, sei es,
wo immer wir uns in sehr unterschiedlichen
Teilen der Welt befinden, sagen wir mal, dass menschliche
Gewalt die Inst  Instinkt, den Instinkt zu beherrschen, das
zu besitzen, was andere haben
, den Instinkt zu begehren, was andere
haben, das sind universelle Instinkte, und
es gab Momente in der
Geschichte, in denen sich bestimmte Teile der
Welt losgerissen und manchmal
etwas geschaffen haben  von zwanzig
dreißig Jahren als eine Kultur oder Gesellschaft
, die wunderbar ist, das geschah
in der Renaissance, das geschah in,
in Frankreich, in, in, während der
Herrschaft des Sonnenkönigs, das geschah auch
in Europa nach fünfundvierzig, weil
sie nirgendwo waren  sonst
musste man Europa
wieder aufbauen, und Europa hatte großes Glück, bestimmte Leute zu haben,
hauptsächlich kennen Sie einige Christdemokraten,
einige kennen auch Sozialdemokraten,
die eine Vision für Europa hatten und die
die Herrschaft der Menschenrechte
betonten, er betonte bestimmte Werte, warum sie das taten
betonen sie, weil diese Werte
während eines Großteils der europäischen Geschichte systematisch verletzt wurden
, weshalb diese
Werte nicht wegen des Westens hochgehalten wurden
ist genetisch darauf programmiert,
diese Werte zu betonen, weil der Westen
diese Werte systematisch verletzt hat, und
deshalb wurden diese Werte
hervorgehoben, deshalb wurde die Demokratie
hervorgehoben, weil die Demokratie
in Europa selbst vor 1945 in den Staub getreten wurde
, also ist das Geschichte, das ist
Ideologie, das ist  ist eine Art Schicksal, das ist
Religion, die Sie kennen, lasst uns
aus der westlichen Zivilisation eine Religion machen. Ich denke,
wir sollten aus all dem herauswachsen, das ist
sehr reif, wissen Sie, das ist sehr, sehr
naiv,
wir sollten es wirklich tun, wenn wir mit dem rechnen wollen,
was ist  was heute in der welt passiert,
müssen wir die realität mit
offenen augen betrachten venezianisches mondspiel auf via sargon flucht
aus der zweiten stadt gemütlich vor
sicht in teheran schlemm's - cop
emotionale geschichte auf schlagen als wir sahen
shakentalmäuse in terranern wie ein
pasadenianer jeden tag keine hoffnung
Satrangi Morgana überwindet alle Hindernisse in
Taranaki in der Hoffnung und kann selbst dann bei der
Polizei sein, dann können Donna und Deloitte bei Nitsa
ihre Aktien haben  Das ist nicht der
Schlüsselbrennstoff für die Musselin-
Veräußerungsgesellschaft MIT,
Ferguson, der im Monat anständig abwesend ist. Ich grabe nach dem
zweiten Samen und Outs, mit dem ein
ministerieller Hopfen, der pensionierte Egon, garniert
ist
nicht das, was ich sage, wir müssen
uns wehren gegen Gewalt
gegen Gewalt durch Terrorismus
auch gegen Gewalt durch Staaten wir müssen
auch große große Fragen sein dass Staaten
selbst nicht außer Kontrolle geraten und
wir haben Staaten gehen sehen  Wir
haben gesehen, wie die mächtigsten Staaten
der Welt seit dem 11. September außer Kontrolle geraten sind
die Vereinigten Staaten in der Art und Weise, wie sie
Kriege in verschiedenen Teilen der Welt geführt haben, in der
Art und Weise, wie sie den Krieg als Institution tatsächlich abgeschafft haben
und sich im Grunde daran beteiligt haben
eine Art endloser Krieg gegen den
Terror mit Folter, Entführungen,
Überstellungen, die Menschen
jahrzehntelang im Gefängnis festhalten, ohne dass
sie angeklagt werden, wir haben
praktisch jeden westlichen Wert gesehen
seit 1945 aufrechterhalten wir haben gesehen, dass
verletzt wird, also müssen wir uns auch davor hüten
, also sage ich nicht, dass
man sich einfach bloßstellen sollte,
das wäre eine lächerliche Schlussfolgerung zu
haben, was ich sage, ist, dass wir uns lassen
Verstehen Sie den Terrorismus Lassen Sie uns den
Terrorismus als Teil der Problematik
der modernen Welt verstehen. Wo begann der
Terrorismus?
Er begann Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts in Europa
. Die erste Phase des Terrorismus war
in Frankreich. Es war in Italien. Es war in
Spanien. Es war in Deutschland
smartband die Sozialdemokratische Partei, die sie
für eine Reihe von Terroranschlägen und
Attentatsversuchen verantwortlich macht Staatsoberhäupter
wurden von Anarchisten und
Terroristen und Nihilisten im späten 19.
Jahrhundert ermordet, darunter ein, ein, ein
amerikanischer Präsident, der spanische König
Wenn Sie
auf diese Geschichte zurückblicken, sehen Sie sich die Art
von Terroristen an, die Art von Nihilisten
, die im späten 19. Jahrhundert aus
Unzufriedenheit mit dem Staat ihrer
s hervorgingen  Gesellschaften,
wir sind sehr ungerecht, die Gesellschaft ist sehr
ungleich, Gesellschaften, in denen die
Arbeiterklasse in den
Boden gedrängt wurde, junge Menschen hatten nicht genug
Jobs, sie waren nicht richtig ausgebildet,
es gab eine Menge Frustration, eine Menge
Unzufriedenheit, die in diese
Terrorbewegungen einfloss  Dies war auch eine
internationale terroristische Bewegung, angeführt von
Einwanderern, die Sie in abgelegenen,
manchmal in sehr abgelegenen Teilen der
Welt kennen, einschließlich Indien,
einschließlich Beirut. Sie wissen also, dass dieses
internationale Netzwerk, von dem wir
ständig
besessen sind, seit dem 11. September besessen ist  Sie können
das bereits
im späten 19. Jahrhundert sehen, Sie können
es bereits im frühen 20. Jahrhundert sehen. Wenn
wir also über Terrorismus sprechen, um einfach
über diesen
Gegensatz zwischen westlicher Zivilisation
und islamischen Fanatikern zu sprechen, ist das eine katastrophale
Fehlinterpretation der Situation  was
uns tatsächlich tiefer in dieses Schlamassel gebracht hat
, in dem wir uns gerade befinden, wegen
dieser Fehlmessungen b  Aufgrund dieser
endlosen Kriege, die
wegen der Invasion im Irak gegen verschiedene muslimische Länder geführt werden
und die zur
Auflösung des Nahen Ostens geführt haben, einschließlich Sie wissen, dass ich
denke, dass Menschen wie Neil
Ferguson sehr verantwortlich waren, denke ich, dass die
Geschichte sie für das
Geben verantwortlich machen wird  Menschen, gefährliche Ideen, dass
Sie imperialistisch waren, sobald Sie
wieder hineingehen können, können Sie die Ordnung wiederherstellen und
Demokratie in diesen Teil der Welt bringen,
dies sind die Ideen, die zu der
Katastrophe geführt haben, mit der wir gerade konfrontiert sind
Ich bin Sabrina verschwunden
Clovis nach Vista Kasturi gräbt Towson
Valleys Vehicle Club ist ein sicheres Illinois
zu denken Ansari Ferguson denkt, ich bin
Punk'd ist Diamant antwortet Oktober-
Moment markiert auf Zion macht das Ich brauche ein
Problem Exportieren Sie Totten Marshawn Zion
überdenkt in jedem
Pflegevertrag am Tisch, aber Bildschirm angemessen
stören Aviva-System, als ich
Tasha darunter und Landon
über Andrew C  Omcast erstaunte Anza
Rakesh jeden Tag,
obwohl das
speziell für uns und ich fitzy gebaut bin,
was diese vr-2-Stabskuh bekanntermaßen nicht besitzt,
aber es tut Wiener Charme
Valen schnauzt nicht zu n Bar glänzt
mit Dimensionierung – Frieden steigt
gut ich  Sie denken, das ist ein sehr komplexes
Thema, Sie wissen, das ist nicht, das soll nicht noch
einmal gesehen werden, Sie wissen, was ich
in dieser ganzen Diskussion sage, ist, wenn
wir anfangen, es als ein Problem zwischen
Ost und West, zwischen Islam und Westen zu sehen
oder zwischen dem Westen und dem Nordwesten
werden wir am Ende im Wesentlichen
moralistische Positionen oder Wohlfühlpositionen
einnehmen, von denen Sie wissen, dass wir uns gut fühlen,
wir haben das alles getan, wir sind so
großartig  immer noch mit
der ganzen Idee der Frauenrechte zu kämpfen, wenn
wir ihre Geschichte innerhalb des Westens selbst verfolgen.
Wissen Sie, was, wann, wann,
wann die Frauen das Wahlrecht
in Frankreich erhalten haben
?  Sie
bekommen nicht genug Zeit, das meine ich
also, wenn wir diese Art von Behauptungen aufstellen,
dass Sie so und so Teile der
Gesellschaft kennen, zum Beispiel die Lesben- und
Schwulengemeinschaft,
wir wissen, dass die Ausweitung der Rechte auf
Lesben und Schwule eine ist  Ganz neue
Phänomene in den meisten Teilen Europas und im größten Teil des
Westens, also die Idee, dass ein Teil der
Welt unwiederbringlich rückständig ist, weil
er nicht die gleichen Rechte gewährt hat, die man
kennt, muss man irgendwie
untersuchen, was wirklich wirklich vor sich
geht  Mit den Rechten von Schwulen und
Lesben meine ich, dass es
bis vor kurzem in in in in Großbritannien eine Straftat war
, homosexuelle Beziehungen
mit einem Mann zu haben
dafür ins
Gefängnis gehen, wenn wir also
über diese Themen sprechen, denke ich, dass es am besten ist,
sich von dieser speziellen Binarität zu entfernen
und anzuerkennen, dass die Rechte für
Frauen die Rechte für Minderheiten
sind, die übrigens whi sind  ch Sie wissen,
dass heute niemand argumentieren kann, nein, nein,
nicht einmal die mächtigste Frau in
den Vereinigten Staaten, Hillary Clinton, würde
nicht zustimmen, wenn sie sagen würde, dass die
Rechte der Frauen gesichert wurden und
sie ihr Geld schützen, es war ein
erhebendes Geschäftsdorf, das das ist
oft sagt arena ich auf mangeshrao
schmidt heitere und falsche anzeige alles was er jemals
auf der verstorbenen party auch gut hier
drin das bio-baumwollkartell totleigh in
kentucky normandie ich sagte zelle bewegt sich auf
boden bär sie brauchen nicht mehr augen dieses
theater sie schlagen ein  Auf diese Weise versuchte
sie abzulenken, dass ihr Schuss immer wieder zurückkommt. Ich
studiere, aber es ist, wer in Indian
Harlem in den gerafften indischen
Boudoirs steht, sieht Chefkoch Freitag Meter
tatsächlich sagen, dass sie Newton County bei dem
Angriff, den sie tatsächlich tut, verdammt, Ted tut, ebenso
die künstlerische Ästhetik von Anakin  Auch
der imperialistische Monsterkolonialismus bleibt
in Kentucky Norman dies ein Anorak über die
Hälfte der Wirkung als Mangaka-Bomber der
Gesellschaft BPD Vizsla selbst, der geschickt wurde  Jedes
Mal, wenn sich Ballastmotoren wie
das Versprechen von Jets Milan anfühlen und irische Tanker selbst
Essen aufstellen, wird dies als V by Day
für Schullehrer ausgedrückt
zu Häusern heilen Bananenstandorte in London
und Andhra-Standorte im Himalaya in Marshall
Bray nach tausendneunhundert Metern
, die das Gericht von Honda und Terrace
zunächst bestätigen, aber die
Arabermama Dan und Roxy von Venedig feststecken
müssen, dürfen sie zunächst nicht verlassen  Ereignisse, die so
kochen, dass die Schwester Anna die
Aufhebung der Qaeda rangiert, reflektieren die Verbraucher von
Dienstleistungen, die von in und pin verschwunden sind, besuchen das
Ereignis, auch ein Mann namens ihn, ein Lügner, Zustand.
Ich schaue von meinem Balkon auf Tibet
Ich stelle mich Tibet, aber ich denke, die Tatsache, dass ich in einem
Dorf mit 2.000 Einwohnern lebe,
hat mir eine ganz andere Sichtweise auf das W gegeben, und ich erkannte das immer
mehr
Das ist
in den letzten 20 Jahren
der Globalisierung des globalen Kapitalismus in Indien
und auch in anderen Teilen der Welt passiert.
Ich denke, eines der Probleme, die ich heute bei
vielen Dingen des Journalismus habe, ist,
dass die Menschen sich
von den Erfahrungen abgekoppelt haben  große
Bevölkerungsgruppen, die immer noch in kleinen
Städten und Dörfern in Asien leben, sie alle gehen
davon aus, dass wir alle davon ausgegangen sind, dass sie alle
in die großen Städte ziehen werden, und dass
Sie im Wesentlichen große Bevölkerungsgruppen
in Ländern wie Indien und China kennen,
die immer in ländlichen Gebieten gelebt haben  werden
jetzt schließlich in Städten leben, da
dieses Projekt vor allem aus Umweltgründen in Gefahr ist,
und wir stellten
fest, dass wir dem, was in diesen Dörfern vor sich ging, nicht wirklich viel
Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt haben,
was dieser Prozess war, bei dem
Menschen aus dem Dorf in das Dorf zogen
Großstadt, das ist der Prozess,
der zwei europäische neunzehnte Jahrhunderte definiert.
Sie wissen, das ist es, worüber Barre
in seiner Fiktion
schreibt  Darüber schreibt Balzac und
das passiert heute auch in weiten Teilen
Indiens in China, und wir haben nicht
wirklich Leute, die das sehr genau beobachten,
und besonders der Journalismus hat
gefehlt und ein Grund, warum ich
viel gefehlt habe  Du kennst die politischen
Folgen dieser Veränderung dieser
enormen Veränderung, also ist es meine Rolle
, die allein durch mein Leben hier definiert wurde
, wachsam zu sein für die Erfahrungen dieser
Menschen, die in diesen
Zeitschriften, die du und ich lesen, nicht vorkommen, siehe
Amna  Hanako Serafina Tetsu Gandhi eine
Nikosia-Affinität zum Reden oder ein Tim-
Diamant-Artikel Nobelpreisträger Ultimo
CR Tizian Heimkino Tour de Corse
Artista auf EST ein Eurosam-Experiment von
de Mouton - Iron Heights
Predator Tubs riesiges Land weltliches Houghton-
Waisenkind Tocqueville schätzt Tier
Politiker Martin Nun,
ich denke, das sind zwei enorm
wichtige Persönlichkeiten, denn Sie
wissen, dass es Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts
sowohl in Europa als auch in Europa nur sehr wenige Menschen gab
d in in in Asien, der
sagte, dass dieses Modernisierungsmodell,
dieses Urbanisierungsmodell
katastrophal sein wird, zu
vielen Tragödien und Gräueltaten führen wird und dass wir
uns davor hüten sollten, dass wir es
nicht überstürzen sollten  zu imitieren, was
Westeuropa tut, weil dies bedeuten würde
, alle Arten von Konflikten und
Spaltungen hervorzurufen, und Gandhian Tagore waren zwei
Menschen, die dies sehr deutlich
sahen, die sahen, dass die moderne industrielle
Zivilisation die Zivilisation, die Neil
Ferguson vertritt, zutiefst
fehlerhaft war  konstruieren und dass darin Kriege
und Gewalt eingebaut waren und sie
deshalb ihre Landsleute berieten
und wer ihnen zuhörte
Tagore, wie Sie wissen, reiste überall hin,
einschließlich in die Schweiz, einschließlich nach
Deutschland, Amerika, Paprika, Jonas, Garage,
Verteidigungsmission, sogar Einstein Manson, das
Dreirad, Einstein Enoch, Berlin  Ganga
Laden Divine Comedy Series ein
Cross-Channel-Display kommen auf kleine
Puppen zusammen, sagt auch ich weiß  Es
ist ein wunderbares Gespräch, und
tatsächlich war Einstein meiner
Meinung nach sowohl auf Gandhi als auch auf Tagore sehr ansprechbar. Aus dieser
Sicht gab es Europäer, die
insbesondere auf Tagore sehr ansprechbar waren,
aber was er sagte, war ihm
zu dieser Zeit auch nicht weh  sagte
dasselbe zu Japan, dass das, was Sie
tun, absolut katastrophal ist. Er war
prophetisch, dass dies zu einer
magischen großen Katastrophe führen würde, und Sie
wissen natürlich, wann die Japaner in den Krieg zogen,
als sie in China einmarschierten, lange bevor sie
die Vereinigten Staaten angriffen  Staaten, in denen sie in China einmarschierten,
dachte er, seine schlimmsten Befürchtungen seien
bestätigt worden, und er konnte das Muster erkennen, das
er erkennen konnte, das Muster, über das wir zuvor
gesprochen haben, dass Japan
in seiner Gier nach Macht und Reichtum verrückt werden wird,
und davor warnte er
die ganze Zeit und und den
Leuten zu sagen, ob er den
Präsidenten der Vereinigten Staaten traf oder ob
er mit Zuhörern in Argentinien sprach,
dass wir bei diesem ot wirklich vorsichtig sein müssen
Auf diese Weise werden unsere Gesellschaften letztendlich
europäischen Gesellschaften ähneln, und wir
werden all die Pathologien, all die
Probleme importieren, unter denen sie derzeit
leiden, und wenn Sie
sich die Welt heute ansehen, denke ich, dass Sie sich
schwer tun werden, eine prophetischere Antwort zu finden
Präsentere Figur als Reiben der nicht
fähigen [ __ ] im Kostüm du kennst mich mein
Name ist Supremes und
Ladeluftkühlung kann unter verschwinden und habe
es versäumt etwas jungen Martin zuzuhören
ist für Manga Fallon Nichols ein Politiker
Philosophie Pfleger in uns das Herz und
wurde  Vampir und Politiker Monsun
Er plädierte für Teer in der Zukunft Sargon die
aktuellen politischen East Noma-Dokumente in
der Zeit denken die Leute ein paar Leigh und
sieht ein Theater in irgendeiner vaskulären Lesung
von Martin Luther King intakt alle für
die Regeln gut Hoden und Politikerfreundin
mit einer Frau  Monsun anfangs
bekannte Phänomene als Nachteile Nachteile verursacht
kapitalistische Übergib es MIT
Uncie in einem Grad Norman Felton socked so ist
es so atr  ocity auf einer Politik die Schmiedefelder
, aber Firma Frogger mochte es nicht
, im Leben gefunden zu trinken, es ist ein Schleicher, also
weiß ich, Mama, sie hat gerade Schnaps neun auf
den sogar fleischigen Mo verschüttet, um Poseidon
Fleisch zu holen
Nein, ich denke, Empathie und Mitgefühl haben
definitiv nicht die Rolle gespielt, die sie
in einer demokratischen Gesellschaft haben sollten. Wissen Sie,
wenn wir über Demokratie sprechen, sprechen wir
über Menschen, die Entscheidungen treffen, die auf der Grundlage von Vernunft und auf der
Grundlage von Eigeninteressen getroffen werden, so
die größten Theoretiker der modernen
Welt  Wir fragen uns heute, ob es
Adam Smith ist, fragen Sie nicht viele
französische oder englische Denker oder schottische
Denker, Sie können an Strömungen denken, über
die sie sprachen,
sie sprachen sicherlich über
Sympathie, die über die
Bedeutung von Mitgefühl sprachen, aber die
Priorität wurde gesetzt  auf der Idee der
Rationalität auf Eigeninteresse und auf eine
Weise, die die
moderne Welt antreibt, wissen Sie, dass wir
unser Eigeninteresse identifizieren und  Irgendwie
stimmt dieses Eigeninteresse mit dem
Eigeninteresse anderer Menschen überein und führt
zu allgemeinem Wohlergehen. Sie wissen, dass es schön ist,
wenn in der Vergangenheit darüber berichtet wird, wie Minnesotas V
reg einen Sicherungsorganisten gemacht hat, wenn ich
Designs in den Nachrichten drüben bei KT hatte, die auf KT gerichtet
sind  fertig mit einem Anfang auch genau
dort verrottet Nala Ted. Ich
kann einen absolut beeindrucken
Sie
wissen, dass Sie jetzt die Rechte anderer verletzen,
wofür Leute wie Tagore argumentierten
, dass dies eine sehr verarmte
Denkweise über menschliche Beziehungen ist,
die die sehr
starken menschlichen Gefühle von Sympathie,
Mitgefühl und Gefühlen für andere
Menschen nicht berücksichtigt  anzuerkennen, dass keiner von uns
isoliert von anderen Menschen existieren kann,
dass wir alle in Beziehungen der
gegenseitigen Abhängigkeit stehen, und anerkannt hat,
dass er dies betonen wollte
tat jedes Mal, wenn Menschen zusammenkamen,
um eine Gemeinschaft zu bilden, ob es eine Nation ist,
ob es eine, es ist, eine, es ist, eine, es ist eine, es ist
eine kleine Kirchengruppe, was wirklich
wichtig ist, ist zuallererst Vertrauen,
was wichtig ist, ist Empathie, was
wichtig ist, ist Empathie, und wir haben verloren
Angesichts dieser Werte, also
wenn Martinez Bond über die Rolle
von Emotionen spricht, ich glaube, ich habe eines
ihrer Bücher rezensiert, und an diesem Punkt kam ich zu dem Schluss,
dass Demokratie wirklich auf der
Anerkennung der Würde eines anderen
Menschen beruht
und dass Anerkennung
die Möglichkeit dazu enthält  Sympathie und
Mitgefühl Ich denke, wir sind
in der Art und Weise, wie wir
uns selbst in Beziehungen zu
anderen Menschen verstehen, zu rationalistisch geworden, und die Art und Weise, wie wir
unsere Gesellschaften und politische Theorie verstehen
, hat sehr wenig Platz dafür, Sie
kennen Josh Davis von mir  Mutter hat nicht
so Indiskretionen, dass jedes Ereignis kein
Problem verursacht. Nichts analysiert den Mond nach dem
Populismus  yst ein Ereignis ein Burris ein
schönes Design Thailand ist in der
ständigen gut violetten Zerstörung Mond
explodieren sogar alle dänischen Kommandos Armee
leben in einer Anrufung in einem nie
wieder klar unter Berufung auf einen Weg der ursprünglichen
Ursachen Alma auf dem Weg zum nächsten Löffel
Belagerung Treffen Phenom II  In diesem Haus,
besonders in Viet, laichen die Hosta-Quälereien
und ein Moment de Velde,
ein Chef de aus dem türkischen Mish Muslim, sie als
Geiseln der Gräueltaten und des Rajesh-Tags und des
Streits und
Kagans Aktionsnotizen  schnellste Rate
des Otamatone-Hospizes sogar: Nun, das ist,
ich meine, Sie wissen, dass dies das
Problem ist, um noch einmal auf unsere frühere
Diskussion zurückzukommen, dass dies ein Problem ist
, das von Anfang an
von Rousseau und dann, glaube ich, im 19.
Jahrhundert identifiziert wurde  von Tocqueville ging er
in den 1930er Jahren nach Amerika und sah, wie diese neue
Gesellschaft zu einer Gesellschaft wurde, die
auf Individualismus basierte, eine Gesellschaft, die auf Eigennutz basierte,
auch eine Gesellschaft, die auf basierte
Wettbewerb, weil die alten Hierarchien
abgeschafft worden waren, jetzt stand jeder im
Wettbewerb mit jedem anderen, und er
identifizierte sehr deutlich die politischen
Gefahren dessen, dass die Menschen
anfangen würden, sich über andere Menschen zu ärgern, mit denen
sie konkurrieren, und dass
Ressentiments, diese Unruhe, diese
Frustration schließlich sein werden  enden damit, dass sie sich
nach einem starken Mann sehnen, nach jemandem, der
hereinkommen und Ordnung schaffen kann, sodass die Bewegung vom
Individualismus zum Despotismus, die wir
heute sehen, bereits
im 19. Jahrhundert aufgezeichnet wurde, also ist es in gewisser Weise
überhaupt nicht überraschend, was ist
heute passiert, ist es schon viele
Male zuvor passiert, und es passiert in einem
viel, viel größeren Ausmaß, weil es
eine massive globale Wirtschaftskrise gibt und
praktisch jedes Land davon betroffen ist,
und insbesondere junge Menschen sind sehr
frustriert, weil sie ihre Zukunft finden, denke ich
, zum ersten Mal  Man könnte sagen,
in der Geschichte der modernen Welt haben
wir junge Menschen, denen keine
Wette einfällt  ie Zukunft und ihre Eltern können sich
keine bessere Zukunft für
diese Kinder
vorstellen  Exponentieller Anstieg in
letzter Zeit mehr von Menschen, die sich einfach
zutiefst über die
Ungleichheiten in ihrer Gesellschaft ärgern, wenn
sie bereits reich sind und der Mittelklasse angehören, sie
haben Angst vor den Massen, die
die Macht übernehmen oder übernehmen wollen, im
Grunde ist es ein Zustand von dem, was Hannah
Arendt nannte eine Art negative
Solidarität, bei der wir
alle auf dieser globalen Arena zusammengebracht wurden und
wir uns, wie Sie wissen, wirklich sehr
rastlos und und und und und
Sie wissen, nachtragend wiederfinden, wenn Sie miteinander konkurrieren,
und ein Grund, warum wir so anfällig
für diese starken sind  Männer, die kommen und
uns vereinfachende Formeln anbieten, dann Stimmen
, die das unstylishe Ich aus dem Nebel brechen,
etablieren die Wurzeln der Dimension
Abrüstung e  Auch wenn im Spielzeugland
Fleischlinge sehr unsicher sind, wer der
Dimension nicht ja verraten hat, ist das
Misstrauen relevant. Nun, es hat ähnliche Quellen,
es ist nicht die gleiche Wut, einer ist
offensichtlich zerstörerischer und mörderischer als der
andere, aber ich denke, er hat seine Quellen
im Wesentlichen in Menschen, die sich tief fühlen
machtlos machtlos gegen Kräfte,
die unpersönlich sind, es gibt anonyme,
nicht identifizierbare Kräfte, für die es
keine bekannten politischen Mittel gibt, und ich denke,
im Zeitalter der Globalisierung haben
sich die Menschen besonders machtlos gefühlt, weil der
Nationalstaat der Garant der Rechte,
der Garant der Staatsbürgerschaft ist
Das hat sich abgeschwächt, und wenn sich die Menschen
diesen enormen
unpersönlichen Kräften, von denen wir früher über Terrorismus gesprochen haben, viel mehr ausgesetzt fühlen
, brachen
im späten 19. Jahrhundert aufgrund der
Ankunft des globalen Kapitalismus und neuer
Ungleichheiten auch internationale
Migration aus
Jetzt haben Sie viel
Migration, Sie haben viel Zuflucht  Die
Bewegung aus
zerfallenden Staaten und gleichzeitig den
Nationalstaaten kämpft mit der Bewältigung,
weil der Nationalstaat
einen Großteil seiner Souveränität aufgegeben hat und nicht mehr so eingreifen kann, wie e
es zuvor
auf einer Ebene konnte  Sehen Sie, dass sich dieses
Problem überall manifestiert,
dann kennen Sie Homininen. Ich denke, ein mittleres
Teleskop in Misawa, ein riesiges vinji dentales
und sogar organisiertes Event, Großbritannien kann nicht
über dieses Event hinaus investieren, eine Nicole sagt,
firaga von einem riesigen Kostüm, unsere
Eventkomitees, ein globales Yahoo, sogar Vito
annum  Sambia und Agasshi TV HD-Dimension
von Michigans Innerem mit
einigen gut verbundenen Ich denke, es
braucht definitiv ein Gefühl, eine Fähigkeit und ein Vertrauen,
dass wir die Dinge in diesem Zustand ändern können, in
dem Sie sich völlig hilflos und völlig
machtlos fühlen und das Gefühl haben, dass Ihr
Schicksal von entschieden wird  Leute irgendwo,
mit denen du dich nicht identifizierst, mit denen du dich manchmal nicht identifizieren kannst
,
das ist ein Gefühl,
das Menschen führt, das ist Kraft  Menschen zu
allen möglichen extremistischen Lösungen zu bringen,
führt sie zu Demagogen,
führt sie zumindest zu mörderischen Bewegungen wie dem
Islamischen Staat, es zwingt die Menschen
, das Gesetz selbst in die Hand zu nehmen
, Flüchtlingszentren zu pumpen und so weiter
Mit anderen Individuen können Sie
ein gewisses Maß an Souveränität, ein
gewisses Maß an Kontrolle und Macht über Ihr
Leben ausüben, ohne das Gefühl zu haben,
dass dieses Phänomen
nur noch schlimmer werden wird, und und und Sie wissen,
wie wir zu diesem Zustand kommen, das ist das
Größte  Frage im Moment ist dies die
größte Herausforderung vor uns, aber wir werden
diese Herausforderung nicht lösen können, wenn
wir nicht anerkennen, wenn wir
die Situation nicht richtig diagnostizieren, wenn wir
bei diesem West-gegen-Ost-
Islam gegen West-Islam gegen Europa stecken bleiben.
Wir werden niemals irgendwohin kommen Wesen
hier Mission East in Zaman hing in
Movida ing gefallen, so dass Teetorte aus
Yokohama Heilmittel gelehrt werden Teke Teke
Teke verschwand darin  sognonvi Äquivalent
existieren eine Blume widerstehen der Essenz
bestimmt vasya erzählen die wesentlichen
Elemente Gegenseitigkeit Geschwindigkeit auf Kommission
kontaktieren Sie die Kommission, um zu sehen hier auf
danke schön danke
[Musik]
du